things are really heating up for people
around donald trump we saw some
bombshells in the january 6 hearings but
additionally his former advisor and
someone who spread the big lie a lot
peter navarro was recently arrested and
is having to beg magga for money to
fight his legal battles
what a fallen star
reading from business insider former
trump advisor peter navarro said he was
put in handcuffs and leg irons while
being arrested after trying to board a
flight at the airport in nashville on
friday navarro was indicted on charges
of contempt of congress on friday after
repeatedly defying the orders of the
house committee investigating the
january 6 riot per unsealed court
documents
so he didn't comply with a january 6th
committee subpoena
and because of that he got arrested and
after that arrest the desperate
complaining immediately began with him
calling the fbi agents who arrested him
nazis
okay
and saying he was treated like he was
not he was in al-qaeda of course the
justice department is disputing his
characterization of those events but now
as greater men such as rudy giuliani
have had to do after being left in
donald trump's dust
he's out asking for money for magga to
fight his legal battles let's take a
look
it's just i mean
this is so wrong seven this book taking
back trump's america help me please i'm
looking at a half a million dollars in
legal expenses according to some legal
experts or more this could go to a
million i've got to raise that money i i
i can't kill my retirement
by by defending this this baseless
charges taking back trump samaria please
go to amazon right now order that book
the book
yikes happy i'm not you peter um i will
say in all seriousness we should not
take pleasure and just because we don't
like someone watching them crash and
burn that's just not cool
no i'm kidding um that was awesome so
in a world that's so tough it's nice to
see people who try to assault our
democracy and spread lies about a free
and fair election get a little bit of
punishment okay that's pretty nice
uh like i said he refused to comply with
a january 6 committee subpoena
and it's a good sign that the justice
department is finally getting a little
bit more justifiably aggressive
in their enforcement and hopefully we'll
see that trend continue
of course only with crimes that have
actually been committed not for
political reasons but uh
if you can uncover real crimes the
justice department even if it's touchy
people need to actually take appropriate
actions i'll be following this story
closely seeing what happens with peter
navarro on my channel you can check it
out luke beasley on youtube that's
beasley why if you're watching on
youtube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
you can just click to check out my
channel i encourage you to do so